go live
okay for people joining this live stream
we are going to be talking about
probability calibration
and i'm not completely sure what that
title means it popped onto my calendar
and uh i'm uh
trying to understand what it is so
etienne can you
start explaining what point is here
so so the idea is uh i mean
in a broad sense is to have kind of
probability that makes sense
uh for for so the output probability of
classifiers
right and um so the definition
for example let's say a classifier that
predicts if it's going to rain
or you know so one of the challenges is
that you know we think we're generating
probabilities whatever probability means
in this case
yeah but people in the end are going to
make decisions based on what we say
and you know it's going to be in the end
it's going to be either yes or no
and what does it mean to say it's
probability of 0.6
is that basically the issue i mean
related yes yes because people will make
decisions with probabilities and so
insensitive areas like in medicine
it's important that they they really
understand what it means it's ninety
percent of probability
uh also when we combine models uh it's
good so that they have
they have calibrated or reliable
probabilities
uh there's all applications but the main
one is is when
doing decisions uh in other words if we
have two models and one of them says
probability
a and probability b you know the
question is are those probabilities
actually on the same scale or do they
have any comparability at all
yeah in some sense in some sense so it's
not so okay let's look at the example
maybe um so in this is it going to rain
or not based on whatever input
right humidity of yesterday whatever
a classifier is said to be to be
calibrated
or reliable excuse me yeah
i got a good step a calibrator is said
to be
a classifier i said to be calibrated or
reliable if
if you take all let's say the all
prediction that you make
you take all of them where you predicted
60 of rain
then among all of them he trained 60 of
the time
well in other words the probability
in a you know in a frequency way of
understanding what probability is it
works going forwards
uh yes except that it's different from a
good model that's an important thing to
to to understand that's what i put at
the third bullet point
uh for example if you were to predict
the class priors
let's say like in this place it rains
you know
40 of the time we know that average over
many days
then you can always predict 40 and you
will be calibrated
but you will be a bad classifier so it's
not
about making um you know
it's not just i mean it's related like
if you calibrate the classifier you will
make it a little bit better
uh but it's it's not synonymous wait a
minute so um
hold on so you're saying i mean this is
like an a poster uri probability that is
in in actuality it rained 40 of the time
and you're saying you could get
it rains 40 of the time but which days
it rains it gets completely wrong
exactly exactly exactly right so when
you gathered all these days
then the probability is correct well so
typically with making models
right you i mean
you know there's something you care
about on the model and there's other
things you don't care about you might
only care about the fraction of the time
it rains because it might be
you know based on how much your crops
are going to grow or it might be you
really care did it get right which day
of the week it rains on
right in other words for different
purposes you might want different things
yeah actually yeah if you average a
classifier that is calibrated then
yes average would be better yeah well i
know but you could take it be the
average it could be a standard deviation
it could be this it could be that i mean
this is the point this is this is the
typical story of modeling
that it depends what you want
that is the question of whether it is
good
depends on what your you know i mean in
in the machine learning world this is
some kind of loss function question but
in the more general world it's like
you need a a meta language to describe
what it is that you care about in the
model
i guess yeah that's another way like
sometimes you might be okay to a model
that is less good according to
traditional loss but
more calibrated so the traditional
loss here would be the likelihood on a
test set
so to maximize the probability of the
correct outcome
right but yeah in this question about
you know the crops
growing at an average rate what you care
about is the average number of days
which isn't
the individual likelihood of hitting a
particular day you know is it going to
rain on monday
that's not what you want to know yes no
that's that's uh
but but it's related it's related right
so i mean
but the question is i mean to me
in the end you know given a model or
given
you know a a how good is this model
question you know if we could have a
language which
described you know
in which you could say i want to compare
this you know this is the thing that i'm
trying to work out
you know i mean we don't have that
really we don't have something which
could
say um you know
you know given i mean like we could just
say the mean of these things
is close to the correct value or you
know in other words it's essentially a
target
it's some kind of objective that is
beyond just the individual
you know uh do the best you can on each
individual
uh output if i'm making sense right it's
a
it's a more aggregated measure of how
good you are
yeah i mean in general we don't need we
it's enough to define things on single
output
and actually in that case if we use a
likelihood as a metric uh it will push
to have the model that is calibrated i
mean likelihood on the test set
the problem is that in practice if
there's some bit of overfits if the
model is you know
not good for for whatever reason then
you end up with miscalibrated um
well so what's your point your point is
that in the end the point is going to be
that you have a particular model of how
a particular model for how good your
model is
which has to do with you know fitting
the test set one by one
yeah but it's not obvious that that's
the
you know what you're basically
explaining here is that that doesn't
necessarily do it
you know for example you might care
about
the you know average um
[Music]
you know let's say you're you're doing
the you're computing things in buckets
of a week
you might care about the average i don't
know what the average
week to week variation of this than that
thing
which is something different from i'm
going to do the best i can in each
individual value
definitely definitely definitely yeah
what we do is a bit of an agnostic
loss function having the log likelihood
and uh
and we kind of assume that whatever your
true objective was
it's going to be correctly captured with
this loss function and um
and then we you can have some utility
functions and things like that
uh so we have we have way to to express
your goals uh more more specifically it
won't change the training it will just
change this
you know the way decisions are made
they're all independent for example
though
um okay so let's just look at these so
so do we go through yeah just the last
two so the typical miscalibration is
what
is of you know overfidden classifiers
for example one type
of miscalibration something that um
you know that always predicts very high
or very low probability
yeah i mean i'm sure if i if i give it a
picture of us something or other
yeah i mean these these probability
estimates for pictures seem totally i
mean
how will we even calibrate that that is
if i say you know
yeah imagine if i i i didn't test but
i'm pretty sure it's miscalibrated
um because it happens to be the case
with model neural networks strain on
images
they tend to be miscalibrated they tend
to be overconfident actually
of course and i mean
yeah sorry go ahead let's just yeah no
no and the way to to correct that is to
train i mean
one way is to train a model on top of
the probabilities
but i don't really understand this
without a distribution
of things in the world i don't
understand what these probabilities
really mean
okay it's it's assuming that the
test uh examples you know the the
example in which the model are going to
be used on are according the same
distribution
and independent uh from each other like
that independently sample from the same
distribution
uh as a training example that's
that's what it assumes so that's kind of
the hypothesis we make
and then we say are we calibrated
according to this hypothesis
of course if the test data is according
to a different distribution then there's
another story
i know but i mean so in the real case
what we care about you know the
the fact that this is a saurian with
0.998 percent you know
probability it just seems crazy to me or
lizard with that probability i mean
yeah if we did our job right
uh it might be calibrated
but i mean at the level of things in the
world
is this a lizard well you know i might
say
i would guess it has a 95 probability of
being a lizard
right but there's all kinds of other
crazy things that it could be
sure sure it's not the true
probabilities that
that's the thing is that it's not like a
perfect classifier
would give the true probability in the
sense that
uh i mean in the center it could
actually be something else let's say you
blur the thing
uh and and that there's not a right and
and you know there's not a
obvious answer um
then a perfect model would give the pro
correct probability
given this blood image it could be 40 of
chance to be a lizard you know
20 of chance to be whatever what what do
those problems
mean i mean in other words if i were to
sample things in the world
i mean i just don't understand what is
the underlying you know
probability distribution okay so it
assumes
that the test data are the same
probability distribution as well i
understand it's the training data right
yeah and if this assumption is true
um then then that's the uh well
the metric is to so so we're learning a
conditional distribution
right yeah but you're also learning a
problem it's a distribution but i i
don't understand what it is that's what
it is that's what it is so you
probably deduction of label given input
and our metric
is to minimize the distance between
the the true probability distribution
and uh
and and the one that we are modeling i
understand but but the thing is that the
probability distribution for pictures
is something very wild that we don't
really understand
perhaps that the word
it assumes that the word is restricted
to what's
shown during training so that the world
is
somewhat represented by the training
data
and in this training data if you pick
something that is
somewhat representative a sample that
would fit in the training that as it is
not an outlier
then the those are the probabilities
that is the distribution that models
the training
look well okay we should we should go on
but i i'm
i'm not buying the idea that we have a
you know in this kind of you know
yeah if you come to distribution you
change your probabilities yeah you write
about that if you change the
distribution of images you change the
probabilities completely
so they're not not valid if if you only
use
your image identifier to identify cat
versus dogs
then clearly there's going to be some
probabilities you know that is not cut
dogs and they are wrong it's just
because we don't have the right prior
information
that's why we have this class prior
thing for example that's one way to to
to control that
and you actually say for your use case
what is the
prior distribution i mean what is the
marginal distribution of the classes
that you will encounter
and this then corrects the probability
to take that into account and have
good probabilities so that's uh
but that's a little bit yeah let's keep
going with what you
were talking about so so yes you can be
over confident it can be underconfident
and typically neural networks are
overconfident at least model one
at least on images when they're trained
on images more than one are
overconfident
why um and not clear why
i think i think people don't really
um i'm going to give you a hypothesis my
hypothesis says
that your model for the probability
distribution is wrong
that is that that the when you think i
mean like
there's a certain set of basis functions
because you're basically modeling some
you know
space of functions and so on or some
pretty complicated space
and um the um
uh and i i'm going to claim that the
reason this is wrong is because that
space has not been correctly modeled
because we have no idea how to model
that space
i disagree with that because you can
have a very simple model that that that
is uh
calibrated again it's not like being
good or bad
it's just about being calibrated you
know not being overconfident under
confident and so on
so i think it's more that um
uh people just don't really care that
much
when they trade like they they might
select the model that has the highest
accuracy for example
and by doing this by not selecting the
model that i have the highest likelihood
you are biased toward model i mean you
know that that not necessarily well
calibrated
i think if you use a correct metric like
the likelihood and you're really careful
about you know
trying values hyper parameters by
architecture and so on and to try to
really minimize the likelihood
then you probably end up with something
calibrated at least i mean i'm not
entirely sure
but that would be my my guess is that um
yeah various people on a live stream are
correctly commenting there's nothing
probabilistic here
right this is just you know we are we
are calling this a probability but it
really isn't i mean in what sense of a
problem
you know i mean i mean
we can go to different probability you
know we can say it's a belief of the
model
and and right i know i mean
it's a word that has some you know where
the hard meaning is typically about
ensembles and frequentest type things
and any other meaning that's kind of
soft but go on it comes from several
origin actually
the first origin is just the inherent
uh noise in the data which is not very
present in in
image classification right this is
clearly something that is
you know but but on many data like
predicting somebody is going to
die or not in on a titanic given their
sex and class and so on
there's no you know perfect answer right
it's only probabilistic there's too much
noise
so that's the main thing then there's a
lack of training data
uh you don't have all the data in the
world so you know you cannot have uh
and then there's a fact that a test
distribution is different from the
so that's kind of the main source of uh
anyway let's keep going i want to see
where you're going with this
okay so then the problem is when you go
to multi-class
because we could extend the definition
directly
so the first definition here is among
all
predictions where probability of cat dog
bird given input is
equal exactly to this you know 0.20.3.5
then if you do a tally of all these you
know
predictions all these classifications um
then the the probability is the same
this is kind of the natural extension
of the binary classifier
calibration and actually we use this
definition to train a calibrator
the problem is that you cannot really
visualize
calibration with this definition it's a
bit
i mean you will understand i'm not
honest you're saying
given that i know it is one of cat dog
and bird
yeah uh are these
i i i'm sorry i didn't understand what
yeah that's that's that's it takes some
time to wrap
around that so you take all the
prediction
where you predict exactly 0.2 0.3
for cat dog and bird respectively when
you do this vector
of probability um wait a minute
so you're saying you've got a
distribution of pictures
and those pictures
it you know you're not ever going to get
exactly point two of course not you have
to do some beating yeah
okay so so you're saying i look at the
pdf
of the joint distribution and i say
predictions it's a prediction it's not
the pdf of the i mean it's uh
it is but it but you're telling me this
is the probability here
this is the yes it's a predicted problem
you're saying it's the pdf of the
predicted probability
pdf at the point point two point three
point
five
i'm very confused no it's not a pdf it's
not a pdf looking
each image gets a probability for each
class
and you have a classifier with cat dog
and birds
and you take all the image where the
model
is in the in the area of feeling that
there is 20 percent it can be a cat 30
i know that's what i would describe and
have and all those images
you've just been there according to the
to the to the true level which you know
this is really a dodge this is not a
bird and so on
and in this in those uh image that you
have built
you check that the the the actual
number of image in each beam corresponds
to those three okay so let me repeat
what you're doing
yeah i think i get it i mean what you're
basically saying the thing i was
saying is not as far off i mean
what you're looking for is a pdf of
you you ask you know this
you could think of your classifier as
generating
a probability distribution it says for
as a function of the image you fed in
you know what is the what is the
probability as a function of the image
you fed in
okay so what you're saying is there's a
neighborhood of images
for which and then there's a pdf
associated with that
um uh you know it with as
as you range over cats as they go from
black to white or whatever it is
right or you know as misshapen or not
misshapen or whatever it is
you are there's a pdf which is your
current um
you know the result from your learned
probability thing could be the result
from your learned probability thing
um that is the pdf for cat right
i mean isn't that correct it's it's some
um
you know from learn distribution go
ahead i mean we
yeah so the classifier predicts a
distribution so yes it's
it's returning a property description
which is categorical
which is twenty percent of cat thirty
percent of dog fifty percent of
bird so that's a categorical
distribution that
the classifier function returns when
given an image
and um and this distribution should
correspond to the
empirical distribution um
of of of i think there's something a
little bit wrong here
in other words i think you've got
you're saying i i don't think it's quite
right i think what you're saying here
is in the end there's a
pdf for
the probability of this probability no
i think so i think so yes i think so
remember remember you don't hit exactly
0.2.3.5
you're asking what is the
no no no no there's no probability of
this probability here
uh okay maybe there's some way to see it
like this but that's really not
um it's just
just you take all your examples that are
kind of in the same they're making kind
of the same prediction
that's it it's among all those that do
the same prediction
but you never get the same prediction
you never get the same value
i mean you do some meaning you can have
a distance if let's if you say
in each example you get a distribution
then those distribution indeed it's it's
like very large family of of
distribution it's also
can be for categorical it can be all
those values for the vector
and you look at the neighborhood of
distribution
which are very similar i mean you can
i know so which is a story of
probabilities of probabilities
i mean that's what you're talking about
there and and
and then based on that you say is is the
distribution
that the the on the frequencies basis
is the distribution that the network or
the or whatever
uh classifier give to the to those
objects
does it actually get give a good insight
i know
of the object
right but let's okay let's keep going
i think maybe the model okay i really
don't think you have this quite right
i'm pretty sure i have but again i i am
i i
i will make sense with the next one all
right okay next one is a simpler the
simpler one okay okay let's do the
simple one it's now
you whatever probability prediction is
made okay
like for this input it brings 20 for a
cat like i don't care about the other
predictions but
for cat it says 20 then the amount of
cats
is 20 what do you mean by the amount of
cat
for for the the amount if you if you
gather
all the images that gave about 20
for cat okay plus or minus epsilon then
you you take all this image then you
look at the true level then the amount
of cat industry level
there's 20 percent of cats in among
these two levels okay let's go through
this example in more detail
okay okay all right so let's take a
bunch of images
and let's um i don't know i'm going to
i'm going to i'm going to do this
i'm going to say do a little experiment
here okay i'm gonna i'm gonna take this
i'm gonna say i'm gonna put a random
color here
okay and i'm going to say um
table of these comma 20
okay and i'm going to say for each of
these i'm going to say image identify
um of that
comma all comma five actually i could
just say
is it a lizard should i just do it so
what should i do image
image what what is the what is the thing
image uh image on c5 i think no no no no
no no i want to do the image case
no imagine stands q yeah that's right
but does that have probabilities i'm not
sure
no okay i mean there's a recognition
prior and so on
so how do i get the probability of the
result
with emergency i think yeah okay
yeah um nick on our live stream is
pointing out that
that there's a question of whether these
classes are mutually exclusive like cat
dog birds
they are they are yeah yeah in that case
but some of these other ones are not
but let's just do this okay so let's
image identify so what i want to do
um how does it work with image
identifier i want to say is it a lizard
um can you say category so you say
lizard i think you produce
so okay the image then i put the
lizard category yeah
um and then what do i say then i say
then there's a number of possible
identification because it will also put
the children of lizard i think
category is like the okay so you can put
okay that's annoying you cannot ask
really for you left for all of them so i
guess you should have to do all
well that's a bit
of a third argument third argument you
might have to do all
and then probability yeah and then you
will find the exact one which is
not a great uh unfortunately we don't
have a built-in classifier that would be
direct for the booting classifier but um
and then you would you would ask for so
this is only this is only
lizard okay so then i have to select
yeah in that
for lizard exactly um so okay so then i
take the lizard
part of that and maybe some of them
won't even have a lizard part in which
case we'll just get missing
um okay all right
we need to put all so we should have
everything including lizard
oh but wait no no but now we we said it
was a lizard okay now it's bad that's
bad
when we said it was a little bit we
didn't say it nothing yeah we say
category second argument we say
it is elizabeth now tell me among the
children of lizard
i think oh you know what you have to
grab the net model to the experiment
and that's going to be direct okay
which also calls to having magnified the
building classifier
so you can say well from exactly my
identify
which won't be the exact same label but
whatever it's okay
now what do i do let's see what
yeah let's see what it did okay um
but now how do i tell it that i want the
i mean
probabilities yeah comma probability is
you can see yeah or is it top
probabilities or something
for example you can do that just to see
what on the top but
then we will want to ask a specific
probability
and it's all the lead like there's no
hierarchy in
this network so we have to go with
european green lines out for example
wait a second wait a second wait a
second wait a second i want to know if
this thing is a lizard how do i find out
you cannot with the net you cannot you
can
identify then let's use image identify
and let's just say all
here and let's select the lizard part of
all okay okay yeah yeah
that would work that would work and uh
it might just be a bit slow underneath
but i guess
actually that works now we have the
probability of this idea
okay terrific all right so let's go
through here
and for these let's say data equals this
um
okay so this is going to give us the
probability that any
oh great what was that about
um oh because
it's just it just wrapped image
identifier you have
the list with the the big green image
just remove the design you're
multiplying the result with the between
your image
i'm multiplying with a big green lizard
yeah the fact that the fact that we have
a language where you can multiply the
result by a big green lizard is an
interesting feature
um okay all right so then let's let's do
this and let's actually while we're at
it let's just keep the image there
okay great all right now you're going to
tell me
okay so now we have let's just save this
in an appropriate place
unfortunately they're all lizards here
so
um gosh what do i have um
you have similar stuff in your neural
net framework folder
thank you
okay all right
all right so now what what am i supposed
to be seeing here
so so you told me so you'd say when when
the probability of cat
is close to and probably lizard in this
case is close
to something or other yeah you could
take all the ones that are next to 0.96
for example what does it mean by next to
well there's a there's a probability
distribution here
it's just just just no just just a
window um
like plus or minus epsilon no but but
that's not right because what this is is
as a function of this complicated
variable
that is this image right there is a
probability so it's the pdf
what we're getting here that probability
there is the pdf
of the distribution of some complicated
distribution
whose whose support you know whose
arguments basically
are those images it's a pdf
for the value uh lizard
so it's not no it's not it's not this
that's not right no it's not right it's
not right it's a traditional
distribution this is not your this is
not all your support
right because you are actually going
through all possible pictures and
among all the possible pictures in your
space
that's the probability of that this
particular one it's a lizard
but this does not consist of all the
space of images the data it's just the
sample
so the you know then you have this pdfs
yes but
that's that's you know that's some kind
of you know probability
yeah that that's basically on on on
based on all the knowledge from the
training that you have that that's
picture
is a lizard but that's not your space
here this is just uh this is just a
bunch of of the
data points you can think about that in
here
and so you get the probability that this
this is the result based
on what we know from the training that's
that's
i understand that but i guess okay i
think i get i think i get the issue
stephen uh we completely forget about
the probability of the input
we just assume that your whatever i mean
it is given by the test set that you
that you are giving
for for checking the calibration so you
give a test set and
we don't need to know the probabilities
we have the sample from probability it
is a test set
so we only care about the conditional
probability
of the label given the input and
and then we will average everything over
this let's say 1000 images that we give
that are representative of this
distribution
so we we we evacuate uh it's true if we
were to compute
right now if it was calibrated or not we
we might need to include probably you
know because we don't have a diverse
set here that is not representative of
the distribution of images
so we will have to you know mess around
with the probability of the input
but but in the normal setting if you
give a test set
you you say that's representative of the
data that this model will be used on
and and then you you you check the
conditional probabilities
and you look if these conditional
properties are in agreement with the
with the empirical probabilities
yeah make sense look at the diagram
maybe that would make a bit more sense
i am so i'm still fairly confused here
okay yeah
i'm sorry i should have tried to explain
it better it's not so easy to try this
thing
i don't know i think it's not that clean
a concept but we'll see
i'm suspicious i yeah partially agree
uh i went i went a long way there were
many definitions and
anyway all right let's keep going so so
so okay here i'll just train a
classifier okay
uh and i voluntarily remove the
calibration
uh post-processing and it's just to show
this new property in classifier
measurements that is called a
reliability diagram
so okay so we give the classifier here
we give a test set
and we ask what is the reliability
diagram
and what it does is that it's um
predicting the probability of labels for
all the image in the test set
yes in that case and it will do a
beginning of these probabilities
and it will say among all the
probabilities that are around 0.1
was wha was the like what are those
error bars those error bars come from
different pieces of the test set or
something
it's because yes it's it's because the
finite side of the test set
and so basically it comes from the bins
there's a bin right
it's a histogram this is the histogram
really uh but it's much better
visualized as a curve
and and so this histogram
is due to the finite size okay so actual
probabilities
in the in the training set or the test
set
that's it just test that okay you know
that there are actually
15 lizards out of 100 pictures
yeah in in in the bin this is really you
have to look at one point what
what okay so so given that the
classifier
said there was a certain probability for
something to be a lizard
is that right exactly exactly
i mean this is all all mixed up hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
this is okay so well this is assuming
disjoint uh outputs is that right
mutually exclusive uh yes
um i mean all our classifiers are
assuming that yes
okay fine so that so mutually exclusive
outputs
it says it's got an output a
um in other words it predicts a certain
distribution of outputs
okay it says yeah i'm
so confused here but i mean there's a b
everything has a
has an output has a everything
when you feed it the test set it says
there are 10 a's
75 b's and two c's
right yeah when you feed in the test set
and then we look how many abs and c's
are there actually
well there's a certain probability for
each a b and c
so how do we make the single actual
probability here
answer what we're doing is we're saying
for a given where we're
uh conflating equivalence classes
of objects if if lizards and pandas
happen to have the same probability in
the test set they would appear
the same as contributions to the same
bin in this picture is that correct
no yes
no it's it's it's okay let's hit that
way
okay i have i have a bunch of images a
predicting this pro
their probability vector with the
classifier so in that case it's mnist so
i have 10
probabilities per example
then i'm going to look in this big
matrix
right all the um
all the cl all the all the cells that
have a probability
around 0.1
which is why there's an equivalence
class of
if pandas and lizards both have
probabilities around point one
they are both contributing to that yes
that
is true true true yes yes yeah true
true yeah it's it's it's it's a it's a
weaker
uh definition of calibration it's it's
using the second definition
when i put the two but it's the only one
that we can
visualize because the the understanding
because you have to conflate the
equivalence class to get
a scale here if you were to say every
single
i mean one thing you could do you know
an alternative calibration in the case
of
mnist you could literally look at you
know for each of those 10 bins
you could just say what's the predicted
probability for that bin what's the
actual probability for that bin
as opposed to this picture here right
so for each bin you would have two
numbers
the predictive probability and the
actual probability right
yes yes exactly exactly and and if we
were to use a full definition we need a
10 dimensional space
because because well we you have ten
ten pairs of numbers i mean that's the
that's the ultimate story here
is there no no no no
uh i think the ten is just a
circumstantial i mean
it's just a random
no it's you've got 10 classes and for
each class
the number of points on the curve is not
the number of classes
no but look look as i understand it what
you get
is for class for the class of twos
there is an actual probability for the
class of twos
and there is a predicted probability for
the class of twos
what do you call the actual
probabilities the ones in the test set
the number of times two occurs in the
test set
okay i think that's another definition
that that's not what we use
that's another definition you're talking
about oh boy um
that's not what we use um so the
i mean the true definition is the first
one that i was explaining for
for you know it's among everything you
predict
with this polarity vector let's imagine
there's an infinite training set okay
then we we don't care about there's not
enough
uh so there are many image that have the
same probability vector predicted
right so among all these emails these
are real numbers there are no two that
are exactly the same
okay i think this is more important that
this business where you say
well we just take an epsilon bin around
it i think that's that's more
that's a more significant sign that
there's something wrong in how this is
being set up
it can maybe we could we could just try
with a binary binary classifier
and and see whether this makes sense and
then we move we we
we go we go over the class
i'm perfectly happy to do it for the
mnist case okay we've got 10 different
pictures
right and i mean if we just do this
let's just run this okay
we're going to run this okay
and whatever we get here
okay fine okay so now for this
i don't know what that means what does
that mean is it
the wrong version i'm running here the
classifier function of method when i'm
for rest what
maybe i'm running the wrong version here
i don't know
calibration was calibration put on
master again
i think so i think so okay and try try
without the calibration
but then then okay we will see straight
away maybe you have a tool version i
don't know
okay all right doesn't matter but but
now what you're saying
is if i look here and i run this on the
test set
so let's say i run that cloud that
classifier on the test set
exactly let's do it for it right so
we've run it on the test set
so you have to get the probabilities to
to do anything so
well but what am i well running for our
stuff
what are we talking about random forest
you need to run on the image
not on the test set i mean
yeah that's going to be all the
time and i need probability here or not
right probabilities yeah yeah yeah
probably
why do i need probabilities i first the
first thing i want to know is how many
of these there are so i want to just say
counts yeah that's my little frequentest
probability
thing okay all right so that's that's
the predicted so now
i want to say counts of test
all two yeah
okay so now let's say um
okay so this is now the relative this is
the shows the level what is this showing
in your in your world so this is the
comparison of what the classifier said
the probabilities were
with what the probabilities actually
were i mean
yeah that's that's not what we are
talking about and i
understand we went on this path uh from
the beginning of the meeting
uh by talking about an ensemble of test
set and and
um that's not really related to
calibration there's no probabilities
here you just look at the decisions
and the number of decisions all right so
let's let's do the same thing with
probabilities okay so you're saying
i compute this but what am i doing here
so for each one of these
can i just say probability here yeah
yeah
it's a lot of these so you have to hide
that probabilities
okay so i'm going to get let me just
make a um
let's not go all let's just say um uh
do random samples do random samples only
zeros
yeah well yeah okay fine but this is
showing me for each
entry this is showing me the
probabilities for each of the different
outcomes
okay so now what do i do so
you have to do random sample although
it's not going to work
all right okay so you can do a ram
sample take take take
you can take all of them it's not really
let's just do it for zero let's see if
the class zero is calibrated
i think that's okay well that's fine
that's better no you need all of them
you need all of them
okay you need all of them and then you
can store that somewhere
and then you can store two you can get
two things from the test set one is all
the probabilities of being zero
the probability of being zero from the
test set that's this thing here right
no no no no the probability of the in
your matrix
the probability of the model for each
example
the probability of being zero according
to the model
i see so that's matt of all comma
zero exactly i probably need key because
it's an association and
and it's not a string
okay exactly and and now
you're going to grab all the one that
are
next to i don't know thirty percent
like ten percent so yes let's go let's
just be clear
there is okay so this is the pdf
of the probabilities predicted by the
the classifier i don't know why it has
those gaps in it that's very mysterious
to me
do you understand why it would have
those caps
here yeah it does some some yeah some
partition of space
and uh and uh yeah
because there weren't any trees
somewhere or something no exactly there
were not any yeah
it kind of was deforested it was
something
on the side of a leaf let's say like
this right okay predict the center of
each leaves
okay fine so so i've got that
distribution it's a little bit wonky now
what am i doing with this
so it's not really to that okay
it's related to uh like you have to
find the position of all the
probabilities that
let's say near 0.1 so let's say between
0.09
and one point one let's say
so you can have the position of that so
i guess you need uh
what am i gonna do with those positions
then you will
extract their labels
i guess you okay okay so let's do this i
can say position
in that of x blank um
and then some of the condition yeah that
it is between
um you know 0.1
times 0.9 so 0.09
less than x um 0.11
exactly exactly so we can keep that
exactly and now we grab
the true labels so you mean by true
labels
you mean your test set of the test set
so you can do tests
i see so test of this comma
this being the list of position
percentage or something instead of all
instead of all yeah
oh yeah
okay okay and now we count how many what
is the proportion of zeros
there's two zeros divided by so how many
things do you have here
not the lens not the lens
number sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry oh yeah sorry sorry
i thought you were doing the percentage
of just before okay great so
so okay so it means that our classifier
for all this example
believed it was around 10 of chance
being a zero
but in fact it was five percent of
chance
not five percent point sorry point five
percent you're right right
point five percent of chance so it's
really miscalibrated in the sense that
all the examples that believe it was ten
percent
if i take all of these well if it's
getting ready it should be ten percent
but it's easier this is the tangled tail
i know i think there's one more level of
interaction here that that's going on
that should
then okay let's walk through this again
okay
this is a useful example here by the way
this is yet another definition of uh
but they all imply each other so you
know there's a full full definition
only in the limit only in some limit to
the implies uh
they i mean no what i mean is that if a
calibrate
if a classifier is calibrated according
to the stronger definition it will be
calibrated according to this weaker
distribution
i have a some a bunch of comments on a
live stream that are interesting and i'm
trying to
parse them but um hold on one second so
i'm still trying to understand what
okay let's walk through this again let
me try and re-explain what this did
okay
so we're asking
what fraction of the time
did it think that the probability of
being
a zero is around point one
no yes that's what this is isn't it yeah
yeah this osteogram is what it is but
that's that's not relevant for the
uh but it is because that's what you're
doing here you're saying
okay okay so the first question is what
fraction of the time did it think it was
about point one
and then you're saying when it thought
it was about point one
when it thought the probability of being
zero was about point one
what was the actual probability of it
being zero
exactly
okay so let's walk through this again so
when it thought
when it's estimate for those data points
that it wow that's a weird weird thing
that is a tangled weird thing okay
so for for certain things i mean it's
very weird because
let's say it's pretty sure it's a lizard
oh but it's only 0.92
you know 92 percent sure it's a lizard
but so what you're gonna say
is when it said it was this is tangled
okay when it said it's only 85 sure it's
a lizard
you're
then asking whether that eighty-five
percent
i don't understand this isn't well that
that's that's very useful
let's say um uh i mean let's say for
medical tests right
um then then if it says if i take all
the tests that have been given you know
95
of being positive uh
then i will have 90 if it's calibrated i
will have 95 that are positive
and so i can take off this decision
based on that
wait a minute if i know what you're
saying okay you're saying
no but i don't okay you're saying this
is
its probability estimate it says
this probability so so you're attempting
to normalize
its probability estimate
but oh boy by looking at
the probabilities in the test set but
but again you're losing
so much okay this idea there's something
really wrong with this idea of looking
at these epsilon bins
right because what you've got is a
probability distribution that is
its estimated probability distribution
right for
you you've got here right
a distribution for each of these yes
here's the point
this is .05 right so as a function
of this value here right
as a function of the or maybe that's the
picture you were drawing
as a function of this value here
you're asking okay that is the picture
you were drawing all right it's it takes
me a long time to understand this
okay so as a function of this value as a
function of
where of what it thought the probability
was
you're saying what was the actual
probability in the test set
exactly exactly
and then what are you doing do about it
are you going to just
multiply probabilities to to renormalize
it
no what are you going to do
then i mean you can look at the other
picture so this tells you
so for example looking at this diagram
it tells you that
many times my classifier predicts
something of around 0.8
okay but actually in the test set it was
0.99
so this clearly means that it's
underconfident
and it means it's give yeah probably
small to 0.5 i mean closer to 0.5
whether in reality they were very high
and you can have actually if you scroll
down a little bit
i put an example of
here's a knight base the one that is
flat this is the extreme opposite
this is something that scroll down a
little bit more that's the one on the
bottom
yeah this is the extreme opposite the
predicted probability might be
you know 10-7 but in truth the
probabilities was 0.02
or the opposite the pro the preview
probability might be very close to 1
1 minus 10 to the minus 15 so extremely
close to 1
but the actual probability was only i
don't know 0.5 or 0.6
so this is extremely over confident
which is which i'm going to purpose
because it's knife based
and um yeah yeah
go ahead well and and so what uh
if you see something like that uh you
you you can apply a post-processing
technique
to make it reliable to make it
calibrated
and uh this is listen there's something
wrong
here this is it it isn't it's it's like
with humans you know there's some
you know there's some there's both the
case we're overconfident under
confidence like
experts that are under confident and
they should
actually think that the christ the covey
crisis would have been better
if you know overconfident people will be
a bit less confident and underconfident
people will be a bit more confident
about
what they know or whatever yeah right
whatever but that's that's what it is
about right it's it's uh
okay so you're saying you're saying so
so
first problem is the first problem is
you're using the word confidence
which works better than the word
probability it's yeah
it's def i was trying to avoid it timote
wanted me to use it more
there's one definition of of
calibration that only use the confidence
and confidence is the probability is
your your top probability
is you know you don't care about all the
probabilities like probably the cat dogs
whatever it's like if you think it's a
lizard
that's your confidence it's 0.9 it's
your confidence
no no that's not what are you talking
about i mean so there's the word
probability that you're using okay
is it a lizard right but the fact is
that
the word probability is pretty confusing
it sounds mathematical
but it's actually something very bizarre
that is barely mathematical
it's just could say belief
level of belief yes
which many people would call confidence
what are some other synonyms for that
um certainty
let's say let's call it certainty for
now okay
rather than probability okay
so okay so what we're saying is
the
well it's not even predicted certainty
it's it's the
the
i know but but that's also confusing
because the predictions
are things like what predict does i mean
this is the
the the model can bet on on one choice
if you were to to play money then
would divide its money
into into separate chairs
this amount on these streams okay so
come up with a word that describes that
i don't think certainty is quite it
either but probability is
like super confusing
trends of belief is okay level of
balance yeah
belief surfing is the best all right
well let's say that for the time being
okay so
predicted level of belief
it's very awkward but but any case
so it's not really predicted it's
generated
respect
right models okay so the
the thing is models level
of belief that's one thing
and then there is the
the other thing that is being compared
with
is the actual frequency
in the data yeah
for this level of belief yeah
okay but what it's saying is for a given
well we could do it the other way around
doesn't really matter which way around
it is for a given level of belief
there's a mapping between the model's
level of belief
and the actual frequency in the data
right yeah
i'm trying to figure out is was the
model believing correctly i mean not
really correctly it's not perfect but
um is is
actually is that is the model level of
belief meaningful
in in in the data in in real life
if if your model says is 95 is 99
uh confident well let's try to avoid
confidence that he thinks in 1998
he would put 99 percent of his belief on
the choice
can you and you follow him then will you
get
99 percent of example right
based on this test set yep
okay all right so that and it's a useful
thing right
if you know if we need to take decision
by asking many people
you know you're in a car and you just
actually go left right you do that and
you're with a bunch of friends in a car
if everybody say their probability with
their level of belief and that everybody
is calibrated
then everybody can speak even the one i
don't know much you know they will just
something is wrong with this picture and
uh it goes back again to this question
about what are you trying to get right
in other words i don't think this is
quite the right thing i mean in other
words this is the question of this is a
single point
success or failure right so in other
words take the example of the
the reigning business right if all that
matters
is the average amount of rain in the
week
is this really what you want no no
that's not what you want
that's not what you want but that's
that's one way to improve what you want
calibrated is one way to improve what
you want but this is point wise
calibration
you could do a non-point wise
calibration that is
instead of asking look this is the
actual frequency of a single
of a single label in the data basically
this is the what point was point
pointwise
will imply actually imply uh calibration
on on on mulching on more on more beings
so no not necessarily it depends what
you do with the calibration right
it depends if you simply multiply you're
not guaranteed to get that at all
in other words if you renormalize the
probability
by dividing by this ratio which is what
i think you might
think about doing right you might
compute this for the test set
on a point-wise basis for individual
data points
right no you don't you you
yeah okay let's okay let's just
let's let's let's uh let's carry on with
that with this id
okay right so so what you're saying is
and by the way
this is in general
this is aggregating across the different
labels
this is aggregating across all labels in
this definition yes
only for the for the diagram because
that's the thing we can visualize
i think it's a nice we could also
separate it by class by the way we could
just look for the zero as we did here
just loops for the one so i could
decline all these
graphs in like 10 different graphs
is there stem class yeah to actually
calibrate we use a general definition
it's just we cannot really visualize
what do you mean you use
you use the actual definition what do
you actually do you divide by
aggregating across all labels for the
plot
but you're saying that what you do is
you have the model's belief
level of belief for any particular label
exactly frequency for each for that
label
not for that label because they are
so so so it's just that okay in the
marginal definition
it's a belief for every classes so let's
say for 10 classes yeah i understand
and then i try to make it match the the
histogram into the chart or whatever
the histogram of these ten classes yeah
how many words how do you do it
how do you do that because likelihood
minimizing the likelihood
but maximizing the likelihood so
so actually you could maximize any uh
i mean maximizing with respect to what
increasing so so it's increasing the
probability for the correct labels
how by increasing the probability by
doing this
by doing for example a logistic equation
that's not what we do we do the most
simpler
model simple model ever it's it's
temperature scaling
it means you are taking the log of the
probabilities
and multiplying them by a number okay so
it is basically dividing
uh by taking a power that that
multiplying the log
yes actually yes yes yeah basically we
take the the probability exactly it's
it's
so your model is basically to rescale by
changing you know instead of a linear
scale you assume that these pictures
basically or these pictures as computed
for a single label
uh can be corrected by basically making
so this is a loglog plot
so you're literally just taking this and
turning that line
kind of not exactly but kind of by the
way it's not a loglock plot
and uh it's what is it well
look at it it's between zero and one so
it's it's indeed
log close to zero and log close to one
is it a probability curve i mean is it
is it based on the normal distribution
or something or what no it's been on the
logit
on the inverse of uh logistic sigmoid
okay
and i also made a suggestion because i
think it's so great because it's one way
to you know
map any interval to it is nice we should
have that as a scaling function for
plots
and uh can we can we do that we just we
want the
we'll need that function inverse
logistics
yeah you can create it but you have to
be custom and then
there's a big of a problem for the ticks
right because it's not
but there's a but there's a the whole
point is there's a scaling function
no i know i know with this with this you
can use with scaling functions and you
put the logit
and you can you can do it right now like
you put logit and then you have to put
logistic functions i mean not logic
doesn't exist
which is also a function we should have
by the way yeah okay um
and the problem is that the automatic
ticks uh
uh it's decent you get the log part okay
so you're saying it needs a special case
for this
for this example yeah yeah yeah it
sounds like a good idea feed it to brett
um but but fundamentally what's
happening here okay so
the part of this that is in the log log
regime
before it hits the the flat middle so to
speak you are basically just distorting
this by rotating the curve
yeah yeah very close to that close to
that okay all right so then
boy this scares me i mean because
in a sense we've got a whole tower of
unknown assumptions here
which i don't really know how to
untangle i mean you know this is the
famous model independent modeling story
right and the trouble with it is okay so
my concern is you know in the end if
people are actually going to make
decisions
about things based on this the fact that
it's based i mean you know
this is state of the art machine
learning stuff but
i you know i think what we would like to
be able to do is to peel back
what's going on to the point where there
is a somewhat understandable story
about you know levels of belief or
whatever else
so that i mean look end result of this
is
people are going to make decisions based
on output of machine learning
classifiers right and the question is
what
what is our measure of success
that is you know the you know the car
goes left rather than right
and therefore you know runs into
something or whatever
now you know what is what is the thing
we're trying to do are we trying to get
you know what somebody might say is oh i
want five
nines reliability or something okay
that's what that that's the end result
that they want in the world
so then the question is how do we i mean
how do we go back
from that to say okay so then this is
what
the classifier has to do and this is how
you test that you're achieving that
because that's a that's the kind of
thing somebody's going to want you know
in the real world we can say well our
level of belief function is this and
this and this
but it's like what does that actually
mean yeah i mean this is all classifier
measurements really
right you do a test set and you compute
accuracy all the metrics
and uh but they said see the problem is
this i mean
yes you're right the test set so what
we're saying is okay
so here's here's what we can tell people
we say
yes all we can tell you you know we
can't tell you what will happen in the
real world with things that we've never
seen before
definitely not because that's you know
in a sense it's like you know unlike an
algorithm
of the you know unlike a traditional you
know
uh you just you know there's a different
kind of
statement and contract that we can make
when
you know when it's using this
extrapolation from examples idea
and so what we have to be able to tell
people is
if you ran it on the test set
then you would get
in the end what we want to be able to
say i think is
if you ran it on the test set then
you know if you tell us your decision
making
and your cost for failure and so on then
we can tell you that running on the test
set you will achieve the following
result
yes okay so that's what we would like to
be able to say and we would like to be
able to say and then
then the black magic comes in and we say
and we've done the best we can
to extrapolate from the test set to what
we think is going to happen in the real
world
because clearly you can get any result
you want on the test set by just hacking
it
you just put in special cases for the
test set and so i
the idea is to have your test set that
reflects
i know but that but but all we can say
for sure
all we can sort of certify is that on
look
this is where the black magic comes in
right the the whole claim of machine
learning is
if it works on the test set it's going
to work comparably well in the real
world
because and you would say well if it
doesn't work as well in the real world
that's because you had a bad test set
but that's really not good enough i mean
that that's you know
it's like saying um it's like saying
yeah yeah
so so i mean what has to be the case is
that that
that most of the time and by the way it
should give you
in a perfect world it would give you
diagnostics that say
look you're i mean we don't know whether
your test set yeah
what's what's showing up in the real
world we only know
you know we are purely living in an
artificial world
of the test set but we are
hoping um people are using
these things on the basis of the idea
that the extrapolation of the real world
is going to work
right so so in other words we could
clearly okay so let's understand what it
is we're we're certifying here we're
saying that on the test set
we have a bunch of hacks that
will get the
probabilities that that it says the
level of belief that it attributes
will agree with the probabilities in the
test set to within some margin let's say
right so it's calibrated it's it's it's
calibrated it's level of belief to the
probabilities that show up in the test
set
it's um i mean test is just for testing
so we don't calibrate anything on the
test set that would be called a
validation set
um okay what i do currently is
inside classify inside classify we have
calibration thing it's automatic
there's no tool to do that it's it's
automatically
uh ram4s is going to be calibrated but
then you can convince yourself by
running classifier measurement on a
test set that was not in the training
set right or validation set or whatever
that classifier didn't have access to
and you can convince yourself that that
right so in a perfect world you would
have successfully calibrated
so that this plot that you're showing
here will be flat yeah yeah
you can see if you scroll down a little
bit with the calibration activated
inside classify
and uh by the way this is a unscaled
version this unscaled version
what did i call classic reliability
diagram because people don't use this
logic scaling anyway
other topic okay okay fine but but where
is the
uh scroll down it's gonna come right
after here you go here you go
now this is the the same that we
spent time on but this time with the
calibration activated
and now everything is on diagonal
after you've done this equivalence
classes
you this picture so
those error bars represent the extent to
which were we to draw this picture
for an individual
class as opposed to aggregated classes
this is just
due to the finite size of the test set
okay but you could
you could do them yes you could do that
that thing you could shuffle
yeah which seems like a good error bar
to have right actually that would be
interesting yeah standard deviation
of the actual labels yes right right
just not just the individual not just
aggregated overall labels yeah
and i can see a confusion that people
might have
thinking that it's actually the standard
deviation well i understand but
there's a lot of explanation here that's
needed to make people not confused
so i know i know i know i was confused
for at least 30 minutes here
yeah it's um i've been confirming the
beginning as well i spent a lot of time
okay let's just walk through this
particular point so this this particular
point is saying
that i mean the binning
i actually claim that showing this as a
continuous line may be confusing
and that it may be better to show it
with bins because after all
yeah the bin see that's another
confusion there because you're saying
it was my original thought as well well
okay
okay fine fine but but the but showing
because it could be the case see here's
what i'm worrying about i'm worrying
about
the case where somebody does this they
run it i mean this is you know this is
the horror
that led to p-values in medical tests
you know
p-values in medical studies of you know
you just quote the p-value
and everybody says oh yeah this is a
valid study this isn't a valid study
even though that is assuming a giant
stack of
of things about how things are normal
distributed blah blah blah blah blah
and you know the end result is people
are confident of things and they just
get it wrong
now unfortunately peeling it back and
saying you know
i mean in modern times probably
there are ways to have sort of
interactive querying of
of the raw data that would be much more
accurate than just saying p value is
such and such
but the infrastructure for that doesn't
exist
and people just you know i mean the
concern here and it's a general concern
with a bunch of machine learning things
is you know people just say that the
classifier says blah
therefore it must be such and such
therefore we do this and we get it wrong
um and so you know i think
our objective here has to be and what is
the objective
the objective is either all we can
guarantee
is that we can tell you that on the test
set you achieve the following things
on the on the let's say on the
validation set
you achieve the following things right
so in other words
okay so how does it go so first point is
you've got the original training set
we have managed to get the level of
belief
correctly calibrated for the training
set let's say
we might not succeed in doing that it's
not obvious we could do that
is it i'm sorry
am i you understand the item is that
okay
so is it obvious that we can always
correctly calibrate from the training
set i don't think it's obvious that we
can do it i'm not sure
we have enough degrees of freedom to do
that um
yeah yeah it depends your number of
examples that you have like like in your
validation set let's use the variation
no no no no i'm not saying that you're
saying i'm saying that i'm saying given
the training
right given the training set well
uh classify yes try to do that yes i i i
understand that i understand that i
understand that i'm saying there are
several places where things could go
wrong
right yes thing number one i think you
might not be able to calibrate it simply
there aren't enough degrees of freedom
in the way this is set up i have to
think it through carefully to know that
it might be the case that you simply
cannot get the correct
you can't get a consistent set of
calibrations it's first place that it
could fail i think
not sure about that possible that could
be possible okay so the first thing is
that you try and calibrate and you can't
do it okay
the second thing you might do is you
then run it on the test set
and then you can say how well did the
calibration work
on the test set right
okay so now the question is and and the
how well did it work
is pretty multi-faceted because
there can be a particular class for
which it works horribly
yes right yes even though in the
aggregate it works very well
but you know it it gets every panda
wrong
and thinks it's a zebra cross urban what
the hell can they call an american
oh my gosh i've lived here so long i
can't remember what they're called um
a um whatever the yeah that was his
curve doesn't show
everything yeah if we were in 10
dimension we could see the full
actually the bars would be too big so
that would be bad as well
i mean the truth that they are not
really calibrated uh
according to the stronger definition
right but the fact is that then
if somebody uses this and they think oh
it's going to
recognize pandas correctly well turns
out it doesn't
but they didn't know that because they
looked at this calibration diagram
and they and the aggregate was pretty
good but there was an outlier that was
the pandas and the pandas were all wrong
i mean it's uh that's different though
it's not about the quality
of the predictions it's just about when
you make a prediction
when you make a probability so but it's
about me it's good
it's it's like it could say i am
absolutely certain this is a panda
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right and
therefore
when it's a i don't know you know take a
different example when it's uh let's say
in the
in let's take the australian emu wars
just to have an exotic example
does it you know is it an emu right um
if yes shoot the emu so to speak right
yeah um and and it could be absolutely
certain it's an emu
because it got that belief level wrong
for that class
you know in other words what's that but
in this case
if you have enough emu in your testing
sets
then you you there is no way you can you
can even
aggregate its side there is no way you
can cheat it
in i mean i don't believe it i don't
know what
let's say you didn't have enough emus
but the fact is it was very certain it
was an emu
right and but all you know is that in
the aggregate
we've got the level of belief roughly
right but for the particular case of
emus
it turns out to be wrong that that's
possible that's possible
so so but that's a problem because
if we then say to people you can make
decisions based on this
and you can make decisions about emus
right even though what you
actually got i mean that's that's the
point we we have to be able to
understand what it is
that they are ultimately going to do
with it right because
if they say well i'm going to try and
make decisions about emus
then we you know roll back and say well
what do we actually conclude about emus
oh whoops we had nothing to say about
emus so
the thing you're trying to do is not
going to work it it can be hidden
uh we we could have this diagram made
for each specific classes as well
if there's a class of interest well i
think that having just this variance
thing will be a good start
or you know if you have yes yes
definitely i agree even if you just show
the min and max i mean if you show one
of those stem leaf plot type things
with you know with the with the variance
and the min max that's a that's a decent
you know uh backstop against the
particular issue i just identified but
but i have no idea whether that's the
only issue and i'm worrying about
you know all kinds of things where you
have hierarchical classes and so on i
mean
you know the end result needs to be
people say they're going to use it for a
particular purpose
if they can describe that purpose what
we would like to be able to do is to
validate
whether against the test data we have is
that purpose going to be successfully
achieved to a certain probability
that's what we'd like to be able to do
that's yeah yeah that's what
kenny bush is about and i know but the
point is what i'm saying is
if we had a description of what they are
trying to do
then we could check that because for
example you know in all these different
examples we're giving like
is the average amount of rain per week
correct
is the you know specific emu level of
belief correct
you know we're asking there you know and
i think in terms of
of users having them describe what they
are trying to do if we could have a
proper language for that
is a reasonable thing to do something
people can understand
the fact that it took half an hour to
understand what this calibration
you know diagram meant is not a very
good sign
yeah yeah it's uh
yeah even though it's a useful thing you
know to know just
if you're probably out of work or you
know i am crazy
and include these things where we go you
know include these error bars
i mean you know there are other crazy
things that could happen i think there
is an assumption of continuity
as a function of of estimated you know
belief level here
i don't know that's correct i mean if we
look up here
look at that that's a surprise there are
holes
right that's not what and and the fact
that there are holes there
means let's say you are in a situation
where you're comparing
belief levels for things and oops
there's they're very different belief
levels
why are they different belief levels why
aren't they you know very close to each
other oh because there's a hole in the
distribution
but i didn't know there was a hole in
the distribution but i mean
this picture is implicitly making me
assume that there are no holes in the
distribution but it is wrong
that is just true
the usefulness of this tool is to know
when you cannot trust it's not to tell
you when you can trust yeah but but
that's not how people will use these
things
i mean honestly i would trust something
that is a perfect calibration line like
what you said is complex conceptually
correct stephen
i think in practice it's hard to have in
you being
comp you know always overconfident i
mean you and it doesn't show
you need to okay well let's prove that i
mean let's let's make sure that the
visualization i mean look
the goal of a good visualization is to
not mislead people
so to speak yeah and and so if we can
you know if there are these cases that
can go wrong then if we can show that by
showing the you know the outlier
in some stem leaf type thing then great
because as you say okay so you're making
the claim
that these diagrams only provide
a um a way of making sure nothing went
wrong it's just like if you're doing
numerical analysis you change the step
size and the answer changes
you know it's wrong if the answer
doesn't change well most people
in that case can assume it's correct
even though sometimes it's complete
nonsense
right and and what will happen in these
things i think is people will
you know they'll see this you know
testing
and they'll say oh the tests work fine
great okay
then it's good and um
so i think our responsibility is to make
sure that
you know first of all that you know
there's no way
something bad can escape from the
summary graphics
but better to be able to give people
something where we can say
you know we can make a statement this is
the thing you're trying to compute
okay given the test set how what
fraction of the time will
you be right versus wrong
right yeah so so long as we can
characterize what they're trying to
compute
which and maybe there's a simple i mean
maybe that's just a question it may be
very straightforward it's just like
whatever the function is that you're
going to run on this classifier
you can just give that function and run
it as a test against the test set so in
other words
you've got a pure function that takes
the output you've got the classifier
right
and you are then
i mean then you simply got to run
whatever it is you're trying version of
that is utility function
so utility function you can you can
state your utility of a particular
misclassification
in particular that's fine correct
classification and and that's uh
that's usually the way things are done
like this yeah i understand i understand
so
and yeah where you state i mean this is
the very you know this is the
this is the ascendance of numbers over
everything that is everything just has a
utility value
and it's like you know the the the
concept i mean it it follows the
you know it's like the principle of
money as well that money is a scalar
quantity
right so that you can just say this has
greater you know this has utility
whatever
it's just a scalar thing so to speak and
it's not like
oh we have to you know it's not a a um
right i mean it's just assuming that oh
there is a fixed
there's a certain scalar cost to making
the mistake
and you know blowing up the ostrich
instead of the emu or something maybe
they're the same i don't know but
but um um
okay um by the way in terms of design
decision
um i mean the name i mean for the
properties related
to diagram i think it's quite classic um
i would prefer having the scaled version
called
reliability diagram and classic regular
variability diagram from non-scale
version that's fine because
i think the scale version is much more
useful and by the way
as long as you put these other things in
to make sure that people don't
yeah miss the outliers but
go ahead yeah the second one is the
option
to turn on and off the calibration which
uh there's no
symbol for that yet um so
i think that has to be done more
carefully yeah
um i guess we can talk it again
okay i think we're going to need to come
back again now that i think i more or
less understand this
um i think we need to come back in but i
really would like you to think about
this
you know testing relative to what people
are finally going to do with things
because i feel like that's the only way
and i
and i don't think
i mean feeding it into a magic utility
function is one thing
and maybe that's a useful thing to be
able to do but also
to just be able to do things like
compute the probability that you got the
wrong answer
right so in other words rather than
saying there's a cost to getting the
wrong answer there's a cost to getting
the right answer
and mushing that all together into a
single number use the fact that we can
output
larger amounts of information to
basically say
you know that the simple kind of user
level thing
what fraction of the time will i get the
wrong answer
i i yeah yeah i mean that that's uh
that's really what classifier
measurement is about huh
if you look at the page you know you
have the you have the
the the matrix sorry the confusion
matrix which is probably the
most useful thing
yes you know it gives an amount of
a given label that you got wrong and
and we have like i think that's a story
for me
if you scope i guess there will should
be one i'm surprised we don't even know
this
is a very lame page if i might say so
this is really lame for everything that
for everything it's doing here where are
the examples of all these things
well they they are if you open up the
stuff
okay that's for neural networks
confusion matrix plot
it's a classic thing sure uh and
uh that yeah and then there's a slew of
um
measures that tell you i'm not seeing
those measures
i'm not seeing documentation for all of
these things let's open open the last
one
open the the basic views
well there's a lot of just there was one
i guess there's a little bit there no
but that's not the documentation for all
these different things
no there's no no all the different
things yeah
okay we should wrap up here but but
there's a lot of interesting comments
actually on our live stream that should
be looked at
um uh take me too long to parse them
here um
yeah it's it's um
i mean i i remain concerned about this
whole question
about you know how we give people
something as close to sort of a consumer
level understanding
i mean imagine you were going to
put product labeling on something that
was using
this technology right and you're trying
to make something like a nutrition label
that describes you know
what it can describe giving a confusion
matrix is not going to cut it
it's got to be much simpler than that
there's got to be something that says
i mean you know i know people have tried
i think we were involved in this at one
point
trying to make you know standardized
graphics
to represent medical test results you
know what's the fraction of false
positives what's the fraction of false
negatives what does this mean
etc etc etc um
i mean i think it will be really good to
get something where we can
go ahead that's a messy business
um usually people like the simple
metrics like accuracy because everybody
understands it
no they don't i don't know what it means
they they quote it
but accuracy yeah a fraction of thing
you got right that's that's the
simplest thing that that we can do i
think i assume most people understand uh
this one error fraction of things we got
right was so that's the
okay and that's
but your test said you know
what is that a categorical
classification
for classifier yeah for a classifier
which is which is the main
uh machine learning model right fine
most of the time is a classifier
and so yeah fraction of thing you got
right that's something everybody
understands
uh although i don't think that calling
that accuracy is terrific
because the fact is you know you have to
there's quite a bit of interpretation
like like
honestly i kind of knew that that's what
people meant by accuracy in this field
but it's sure different from what people
mean by accuracy in numerics and other
areas
yeah you have the error as well which is
one minus that fraction of things you
got wrong
which is often better actually when your
accuracy is high it's kind of useless to
say nine nine you know just say you know
one percent of error
uh this is very clear one percent of
error
it's like okay i got a mistake one
percent of the time this
is pretty clear but but the biggest
problem
and this is hard to solve is that the
the in the real world it's different
from the test set as you said
sure and uh it's a shift in the
distribution and we try
to uh to to give a dent at that with
anomaly detection
you can put an animal electro in the
classifier that tells you
that you know doesn't have the same
statistics as the data in the training
right uh but it's not perfect either uh
you know
you can have uh and even sometimes you
want to detect out of your training set
but right and i mean obviously you can
you can hack it again by saying
let's have 10 test sets and let's
compare what happens
you know how how much do the things
agree from the different test sets
and that's some proxy but of course you
don't know whether the distribution of
test sets
uh you know accurately reflects the
distribution of things
cases you know the real world may change
and it may be you know may do unknown
things
yeah there's a push for that actually to
change the benchmarks
to have benchmarks where the test set is
not on the same distribution the
training set
and so you have to use some sort of
tricks to
give good prediction even when you're
out of distribution even when you have
you know
data that are a bit weird even on our
clients basically doing good predictions
and outliers as well
and this is something that is uh but so
i mean
anomaly detection so you know again in
terms of the consumer side of it
you know if it fails the anomaly
detector which of course
is not you know we can't guarantee that
you know just knowing that certain
aspects of the statistical distribution
agree does not mean that you will agree
on you know when you actually do the
classification
um but okay there's there's more to
discuss here
and i think i mean in terms of i guess
jesse was not on this call but i think
that this
in terms of the kind of explainable
machine learning story
this is clearly a place where that you
know
this is a simpler case of that we're not
even talking about what happens inside
the model
we're simply talking about what you know
uh
you know relative to the the standard
machine learning training how well we do
and so on
yeah yeah all right
um yeah a lot of suggestions here about
um
um uh which we should look at
i wish i could stay longer but i am
super late for something else
so okay very interesting stuff etienne
i'm sorry it took me a really long time
at the beginning
yeah that's all right it's a messy one
which is yeah
right it's also it's a it's a data point
that the time it takes to understand it
is a data point of something
yeah it's used for information right uh
um but and i think we do want to i mean
let's think about this some more and we
should follow up on this
um and uh okay and thank you very much
to people on live stream lots of good
comments which we still need to analyze
all right go